etwas gedacht und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video ja leute ich hoffe
natürlich dass google sich schon ich
freue mich machen heute nach ewiger zeit
die man mich gefragt alex kommt
eigentlich gar keine videos mehr machen
wir mal wieder einmischt video und nicht
irgendeins sondern ich glaube ein
verdammt interessantes und zwar wenig
setzen sie auf die idee gekommen
vielleicht kennt ihr noch dieses video
wo ich einfach mal alle apple-produkte
dies so auch wo es gibt auch dort
gestellt habe das müsste schon so lange
ist das her hast ja wenn nicht sogar
schon ja und seitdem kam natürlich das
eine oder andere neue produkt raus und
apple was es dann auch irgendwann auch
es gab ja ein neues iphone und wir haben
diese airports max wir haben airports
froh ich weiß gar nicht ob sie damals
schon gar keine ahnung auf jeden fall
habe ich mit einem gestellten handy
slutwalks
airports max airports pro das pac man
jetzt mal aus und ich bin gespannt was
sich auf diesen ganzen marco getan hat
und ob die produkte gut sind oder ob man
damit was anfangen kann weil man muss ja
einfach sagen apple produkte sind immer
teuer und ich hab schon so oft leute auf
der straße getroffen
mit video gesehen ich habe bei uns
bestellen weil du es empfohlen hat mal
gucken dort habe ich da zwar noch nichts
empfohlen aber wir schauen jetzt einfach
mal ob man heute irgendetwas von diesen
sachen empfehlen kann glaube das ist
auch schon das erste produkt ist echt
extrem lange drauf gewartet was dann
immer ein bisschen schade ist ihr könnt
mir aber super gern mal daumen nach oben
da das wenn ihr sagt alex du musst jetzt
wieder mehr videos machen bestellte
öfter kann ich auch verstehen ich frage
mich auch wieso ich das so selten mache
früher habe ich das ja wie viel öfter
gemacht hier kann man sehen wie haben
wir das model p 9 so sieht es aus ist ja
ganz klar jeder von euch kennt ja die
airports merkte ich mal von außen kosten
ich habe nachgeschaut aktuell 159 euro
und die hier haben jetzt glaube ich mit
versand vielleicht 30 gekostet ich werde
euch auch immer eine kleine anwendung
geben was ich da genau bestellt haben um
euch das produkt einmal zu zeigen auch
weshalb man hier ist mein kollege gesagt
jetzt bei infos dazu okay was geht ab
leute herzlich willkommen aus der
zentrale dann wandelt dmx die airports
max die dürftig nicht ganz so nennen
aber das ist ja klar was damit gemeint
ist eben stets neues drahtloses airmax
bluetooth headset pipapo kopfhörer hier
gibt es in verschiedenen farben ich habe
die so in schwarz bestellt hier steht
soweit die laufen drei bis vier stunden
wenn sie voll aufgeladen sind und um die
bewertungen hier sind leider nicht ganz
so gut also ja 1,8 ich ahne böses leute
aber wir packen es vielleicht überrascht
es mich ja ich bin echt gespannt ob man
damit gut entspannt musik hören kann im
flieger oder wo auch immer mit den p
neuen globales der headset in germany
haben wir einmal die kopfhörer ladekabel
und ein aux kabel wird auch mitgeliefert
da man immer gebrauchen so eine aufgabe
jetzt bin ich wirklich mal gespannt also
eigentlich bin ich mir sicher ich habe
die im schwarz bestellt das ist schon
wirklich kann man sich hier einmal das
foto anschaut und dann die kopfhörer so
einer hand hat also die seen auf den
fotos auf jeden fall deutlich
qualitative aus wie chen tao vielleicht
achten scheiße hier haben wir knöpfe
lauter leiser hier gehen sie an mal
gucken ob noch akku drauf ist
hahaha das klingt doch könnt ihr euch
noch an diese airports videos erinnern
die ich früher mal gemacht habe euch so
immer dem sound getestet haben das ist
jetzt ein bisschen back to do mut haben
wir übrigens auch vor eineinhalb monaten
habe ich mir im mai von 12 max gekauft
was ich jetzt auch auf licht gestellt
habe und er ist auch nicht mehr das
passieren konnte das ist mir noch nie
passiert der blutigste weit ist
connected texas dolly war eine sehr
erotische stimme die einen hier empfängt
dann hören wir doch einfach mal rein und
ich kann euch aber schon direkt
eigentlich glaube das wird nicht okay
okay warte ich höre gerade und bauen sie
kokain das spiel jetzt gestellt
machen wir einmal auf höchster stufe
ohne scheiß ich hab's dir viel viel
schlimmer vorgestellt das ging halbwegs
klar der bassist gut da ja das war ja
sonst immer das problem dass hat immer
so ein bisschen metallisch vielleicht
also auf jeden fall nicht neu es sich
angehört wie gesagt ich habe es mir
schlimmer vorgestellt ist in ordnung nur
was halt wirklich super schade ist dass
jesus quietschen na ja ich hatte die
originalen airports max einmal schon auf
und auch musik darüber gehört ist
natürlich eine super erfahrung deswegen
wenn man das geld hat kauft euch die
aber für 17 euro plus versand habe ich
mein ich bezahlt habe ich die jetzt auch
kein nicht empfehlen also ist in ordnung
nur man sieht halt schon dass es ein
fake ist das ist ja ganz klar machen
weiter mit dem nächsten produkt und
schau mal was ich noch so bestellt hat
das habe ich so auch noch nicht erfahren
ich weiß nicht vielleicht ist es
normalerweise kam fast alle produkte
immer einzeln an weil es gibt ja so
viele verschiedene händler hier wurden
jetzt drei meiner bestellung gekoppelt
und in ein paket gepackt mit einer
sendung hatte ich sonst noch nie
zumindest kann ich mich nicht daran
erinnern deswegen das ist ja gut und
hier haben wir jetzt
weitere produkte ist das eigentlich
immer noch alles fans wir hatten ja
sonst war hier geschichten aus fans in
the dark angel sandrock schade leute na
ja womit fangen wir an hiermit oder hier
mit leuten kommen dass das hier nicht
wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht die kopfhörer
ich denke mal das ist sie apple watch
series 7 ganz neu auf dem markt war ich
glaube die ist doch nicht mal auf dem
markt gibt es die chance wir haben hier
tatsächlich eine naja ok hier muss ich
aber wirklich sagen so ganz hier diese
icons klar das kommt mir bekannt vor
dass hier vielleicht auch wie das auch
okay itunes ja klar es soll an sich eine
apple watch sein das lustig ist das ist
die series 7 hier die gibt es noch gar
nicht und vielleicht ist sie ja sogar
ganz cool irgendwann habe ich auch schon
mal eine bestellt aber das war ein
modell das ist schon viel viel älter die
werden ja auch wahrscheinlich besser ich
glaube die meisten von euch wissen was
man mit smart work so alles anstellen
kann anrufe tätigen musik darüber hören
und so weiter und so fort damit zurück
ins studio
hinein handel premium quality ja apple
sagt die kommt erst mitte september raus
willst sagt bei uns nicht wir haben die
schon im sortiment ich glaube ich 16
euro plus 9 euro versand einmal hier
eine starting at ist auch dabei haben
wir hier einmal die uhr und dann das
abenteuer das armband gefällt mir gut
glaube in dem letzten part von diesem
video hatten wir auf die smart watch
oder die apple watch dabei die hat
damals gar nicht so schlecht
abgeschnitten ich fand die in ordnung
bei dem preis kann man jetzt auch nichts
wildes erwarten und die hier selber noch
zusammenbauen frechheit dort geht denke
ich mal ganz schnell wir klinken uns
hier einmal ein also die musste wirklich
voll mit tahir einpressen mit dem
verschluss ist gut gelöst sagt und hier
gehts dann machen wir das ding mal an
ich hoffe es geht an der ja was ist
jetzt hier bundeswehreinsatz kleine
technische probleme das gerät geht nicht
an aber kein problem dafür habe ich ja
hier das wireless charging pad wir
gucken jetzt nur ob das funktionieren hh
heute schaut man als leser sind so 2
nennen sie mal sensoren darunter du
musst halt genau treffen sonst
funktioniert ist aber es geht jetzt wir
machen weiter ich würde mal sagen bevor
plätze das neue iphone 12 promax
auspacken welches übrigens auch riesch
hat das singen nicht nur drei kameras
sondern gleich vier was ist das fünf
legs wenn du damit in die schule kommen
du hast einfach ein iphone 12 mit vier
kameras ich weiß wirklich nicht genau
was ich die hersteller dabei denken aber
gut es scheint gut zu funktionieren also
und bevor ich am ende vergessen alle
sachen bekommt ein zuschauer von mir
alle sachen schreibt einfachen letzten
kommentar und im besten fall abonniert
er noch alexy ja was haben sie denn hier
wieder ganz so jetzt hammers arbeit auf
instagram post ich bin dann immer in
meine story deswegen schreibt am besten
euren instagram namen dazu hier ich
bestellt die erst drei proben was ist
das na klar das sollen die neuen
airports pro-russischen sein wird sagen
da kann ich eigentlich gar nicht so viel
zu sagen features warte max active noise
cancellation yes hallo das ist ja so
fähig sogar ganz kurz dazu also ich
nehme diesen part nach dem part auf den
ihr im studio gesehen hab von mir ich
habe ja schon getestet und haben
definitiv kein neues kennen zu legen es
würde mich extrem boden 12 bzw gut
wahrscheinlich 120 euro genau aber
schaut selbst wir haben hier wirklich so
eine brutale bunte verpackung muss ich
sagen will ich geil dass sie lies aus
und die kopfhörer oder airports pro
geschlecht oder zumindest auf der
verpackung her ich gekauft für 21 euro
plus 7 euro versand man glaube ich nicht
meckern vor einem jahr haben die überall
noch über 40 gekostet auch die fakes
aber ist ja klar dass mit der zeit
günstiger wird ich frag mich wann apple
wohl an diese wunderbare verpackung
anknüpfen machen wir mal die folie ab
das ist schon mal sehr gut wenn man sie
ausmacht leuchtet sie nicht so brot und
blau auf mich zu - moment würde sagen
auf den ersten blick keine original hier
ich habe keine airports profi das aber
ziemlich gut aus muss ich sagen
ansonsten an die experten von euch was
meint haben wir da irgendwelche
unterschiede ich würde sagen nein und
das case von der qualität ist ja auch
nicht schlecht die chinesen werden was
das angeht auf jeden fall immer besser
weil ich kann mich noch so an cases
erinnern die waren wirklich für die
tonne und das hier ist ganz in ordnung
schwante 1 20 euro wenn jetzt auch noch
der sound gut ist dann ist ja alles gut
tag manchmal aus japan
im rücken for good news for women to
make the ring ist nur spaß leute haben
wir so schon ab 3 die stimme hier nicht
so ganz erotisch wie bei den airports
max davon ich ihnen deutlich angenehmer
das ist schon mal nicht so gut leider
funktioniert nur der linke okay jetzt
können wir das kurz vor versuchen zu
fixen
jetzt funktioniert es okay
ihr habt wahrscheinlich ihr sehen ich
bin nicht so abgegangen wie bei den
airports merkt einfach an der
soundqualität also die ist nicht so gut
leider hat's control hammer das
leider nicht meine ehrliche meinung dazu
ist kauft euch die besser nicht
vielleicht gibt es doch besser ich habe
halt wie genommen mit den meisten
bewertungen oder die die auch ganz oben
angezeigt oftmals ist auch so ihr wisst
es wenn ihr irgendwas bestellt dass wir
da fünf mal angezeigt aber im endeffekt
ist alles vom gleichen händler deswegen
bin ich mit diesen airports groß jetzt
nicht so glücklich beziehungsweise den
ap drei würde ich sagen machen wir
weiter mit dem smartphone auch so ich
habe es gar nicht gesagt wie apple watch
mache ich am ende die muss erst mal
aufladen jetzt bin ich mal gespannt was
wir hier für ein handy vorfinden jetzt
kommen wir zur größten frechheit dieses
videos ich hatte wirklich dies so ein
bisschen hoffnung dass das lustig wird
und auch na ja schon nah am original ist
also früher waren die fake iphones die
man auch ruhiggestellt hat deutlich
näher am original ich hatte sogar mainz
habe ich die folie abgezogen da war
einfach apple logo drauf also die hat
man so ein sticker drüber geklebt aber
jetzt gebt euch hier diese fotos sieht
anders aus wir haben hier einfach vier
camps haben wir auch die apple icon die
uhr hier unten safari und so weiter und
hier kann man auch ganz klar sehen das
sieht schon sehr nach ios auf ok hier
muss ich dann sagen nicht mehr so ganz
zumindest war es geht also immer noch
deutlich mehr als bei dem was ich da
jetzt auspacken schaut selbst leute sie
haben wtf junge das ist wirklich es ist
einfach eine frechheit junge sieht das
auf dem iphone 12 comics überhaupt nicht
mehr also die fotos weichen komplett
natürlich was ich ausdrücklich einmal
unterstreichen wollen wir keine fakes
fördern das ist natürlich kacke und ich
sage ja auch nur meine ehrliche meinung
zu den milchprodukten dann die halt
deutlich günstiger sind als das original
aber das hier ist wirklich
leute die jetzt hier nochmal das iphone
von wish und hier die fotos von drei so
dass da so einige schon enttäuscht das
hat drei von fünf sternen wie kann denn
das 3 habe das musste ja eigentlich gar
keinen haben was haben wir noch dabei
ist es halt irgendwann noname
android-handy was als iphone verkauft
wird wahrscheinlich sind die meisten suv
das wieder umzutauschen ich weiß auch
nicht wir machen das mal kurz an das hat
mich übrigens schule hat 20 euro
gekostet mit versand ja also ich bin mir
sicher wenn ich hier in den nächsten
handy laden gehe finde ich ein viel
besseres für 120 euro das auch wieder
lehrer ich muss das aufladen bis gleich
die leute jetzt musste ich gerade das
fällt kaum ich kann ich das iphone kann
ich musste dieses handy auf jeden fall
gerade öffnen um jetzt hier von der
batterie den streifen abzuziehen damit
das ding überhaupt angeht ich hoffe mal
es geht jetzt an also sowas habe ich
auch noch nie erlebt ja ich sehe das am
liebsten würde ich das direkt wieder
zurückschicken das ist die sonne scheint
wirklich 120 euro wenn ich einfach nur
betrug kamera auch absolut miserabel
also das geld für dieses handy hole ich
mir so zurück das ist mit der größte
flop den ich hier ruhig gestellt habt
was willst du machen dafür ist jetzt die
apple watch series 7 aufgeladen und die
schnüre ich mir jetzt mal als armband
weil ich fahre jetzt gleich nach hause
ich bin ja gerade im büro und mal
schauen was sie so kann wir sind also
gleich wahrscheinlich im auto wieder so
leute wie wunsch ist installiert
bisschen schwierig zu film ihr könnt
hier sind ich habe die auch schon
connected touch funktioniert so sehen
erster eindruck
naja ich kann gleich mehr zu sagen aber
leute vom look her muss man wirklich
sagen sieht 11 echt aus leute was soll
ich sagen ich glaube es war dringend mal
wieder notwendig ein paar wunschprodukte
auszupacken ich hoffe ihr hattet eine
menge spaß beim zuschauen und konnte ein
paar infos mitnehmen also das meiste
davon lohnt sich überhaupt nicht diese
airmax kopfhörer fand ich noch ganz gut
also die kann man schon vielleicht
weiterempfehlen der rest braucht es auf
keinen fall leute es lohnt sich einfach
nicht ich habe trotzdem was hat euch
gefallen lassen doch nach oben dafür
weitere will davon auf jeden fall wieder
mehr machen auch gerne bisschen mehr
geld ausgeben als früher kann man
einfach auch noch geile produkte kaufen
abonniert zurück in den kanal und falls
irgendwer die sachen haben will
kommentar und dann schicke ich die euch
zu danke fürs zuschauen leute wir sehen
uns